how's it going everybody so there has
been a lot of talk right now a lot of
buzz going around about the Russo
brothers firing Mark Ruffalo Mark
Ruffalo not too long ago went on Jimmy
Fallon and he supposedly dropped a big
spoiler for vendors for which was the
title now this was just a big publicity
stunt he did not actually reveal the
title on the show but it was still said
that he was fired after and recently Joe
Russo did a Q&A in which he actually
said yes we fired Mark Ruffalo so
everybody has been asking a ton of
questions lately about whether or not
Mark Ruffalo was truly fired so I'm
going to break it down and debunk it all
in this video for you all so I'm still
doing my giveaway giving away copies of
infinity war Deadpool 2 and ant-man and
the wasp on blu-ray as well as some
special edition posters if you want to
enter the giveaway for your chance to
win all you have to do is subscribe to
my channel like this video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero okay so for starters
Mark Ruffalo was not fired the Russo
brothers did not fire Mark Ruffalo it
was all a big joke and and are you
allowed to talk about these things I
know you get in trouble but recently
there have been a lot of articles and a
lot of video stating that Mark Ruffalo
has indeed been fired and this has come
from a QA that Joe Russo did in which he
stated that he did fire Mark Ruffalo but
again this was a joke and I'll take you
back to where the joke originated and
why it's dragged on so long and why
people are still saying that he's been
fired so on October 5th
Mark Ruffalo was set to appear on the
Jimmy Fallon show and before the show he
tweeted at Jimmy Fallon saying I trust
that you will cut my spoiler slip on the
show tonight that was off the record
homie please don't get me in trouble
with Marvel Barry again DM me back again
this was just a publicity stunt to get
people to watch the Jimmy Fallon show he
didn't reveal anything on the show
although they tried to make it look like
he did he did it I think I could
probably tell you that I think it's out
there already that the the title of the
next Avengers movie is
but the researchers tweeted mark ruffalo
back and said mark you're fired this was
just a joke they were obviously in on
the Jimmy Fallon teaser and you can
clearly tell it's a joke because one
they're not gonna fire anybody over
Twitter and two they keep the joke going
for several weeks after it happened a
couple of days after the tweet Mark
Ruffalo replied guys dot dot dot can we
talk about this about a week later the
Russo brothers posted another one of
their cryptic images to Instagram and
Twitter with the title hashtag wrapped
in which Mark Ruffalo replied this and
you fired me for a measly slip of the
title spoiler alert the next day the
Russo brothers replied to him saying
you're still fired mark and which Mark
Ruffalo replied I don't know what to say
again this was all just one big joke but
there were people who posted articles
and videos who said Mark Ruffalo fired
confirmed by directors and the problem
was that people didn't actually read
these articles or watch these videos
because if they did they would have
known that it was just a big joke but
some people didn't and they started
making their own articles and doing
their own videos simply based off the
tweets so there was a lot of confusion
going around and then the firing of Mark
Ruffalo got brought up again when Joe
Russo did his Q&A on Thursday during the
Q&A somebody asked how the creative team
would keep the likes of Mark Ruffalo and
Tom Holland from spoiling Avengers for
Joe Russo turned his bartender who said
didn't you fire Mark Ruffalo and brew so
quickly replied yes we fired my crew
flip marks fired again clearly a joke
but a lot of people took to the internet
and said Mark Ruffalo is fired confirmed
by directors so that's why you hear
everybody talking about Mark Ruffalo is
fired but in reality he's not this is
just a joke that's been dragged out for
a pretty long time Mark Ruffalo will
definitely be playing Bruce Banner slash
the Hulk in Avengers 4 no worries there
so to everybody who was wondering and
worried that Mark Ruffalo was fired
do not worry anymore he was not fired so
I hope this cleared some things up for
you for those of you who were worried
about it but let me know what you think
in the comments down below and of course
don't forget to subscribe comment and
like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers 4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]